World War one was supposed to be the war
to end all wars
and it didn't
how did how did World War One
paved the way to World War II Every
Nation probably has their own story in
this trajectory towards World War II
how did Europe allow World War II to
happen at the Soviet Union Russia
Allah was the two to happen in how did
America allow World War II to happen in
Japan yeah you're right the answer is
different for each country right uh that
in some ways in Germany and the culture
of defeat and the experience of defeat
at the end of World War One leads to a
culture of resentment recrimination uh
finger-pointing blame that makes German
politics very
ugly um as one person puts it brutalizes
uh German politics
um you know pleases resentment at the
core of the populace and its politics
yeah and you know so in some ways that
lays the groundwork for the kind of
politics of of resentment and hate that
that comes from the from the Nazis
um you know for the United States in
some ways the failure to win the piece
um uh you know uh sets up the
possibility for for the next War right
that um that the United States uh you
know through Wilson is sort of crafting
a new international order in order that
this will be the war to end all wars but
because the United States failed to join
the League of Nations
um you see that the United States really
sort of on the hook for another
generation
uh in Asia the story is more complicated
right um and I think it's worth bearing
that in mind that that World War II is a
two-front war um it's it starts in Asia
for its own reasons
um world war one is transformative for
Japan right um it is a time of massive
economic expansion and a lot of that uh
sort of economic wealth is poured into
sort of Greater industrialization and
militarization and so when the military
Wing um uh in Japanese politics takes
over in the 1930s there in some ways uh
flexing muscles that come out of the
first World War
can you talk about the end of World War
One the Treaty of Versailles
um has what's interesting about that
Dynamics there
of the parties involved
of uh
how it could have been done differently
to avoid the resentment is there or
again is it inevitable
so the war ends and very soon even
before the war is over
um the the United States in particular
is trying to shape the peace right and
the United States is the central actor
at the Paris peace conference in 1919
Woodrow Wilson is there
he's presiding
um and he knows that he calls the shots
so he was respected he was respected but
uh but resentfully in some ways by by
the the European powers Britain and
France and Italy to a lesser extent who
you know felt that they had sacrificed
to more
um they had two goals right they wanted
to shape um the the imperial system in
order to make sure that their you know
kind of fundamental economic structures
wouldn't change and they also wanted to
um sort of weaken Germany as much as
possible right so that Germany couldn't
rise again what this leads to is a peace
treaty that
um you know maintains some of the
fundamental conflicts of the imperial
system and
um makes uh bankruptcy Germany uh
starves Germany and kind of feeds this
politics of of resentment that make it
impossible for Germany to kind of
participate in European order
so people like uh historian Neil
Ferguson for example make the case that
if Britain stayed out of World War One
we would have avoided this whole mess
and we would potentially even avoid
World War II
there's kind of counterfactual History
do you think it's possible to make the
case for that that there was
a a moment especially in that case
staying out of the war for Britain that
escalation to a global war could have
been avoided and one that ultimately
ends in a deep Global resentment so
where Germany is resentful not just of
France or particular Nations but is a
resentful of the entire
I don't know how you define it the west
or something like this the entire Global
world
I wish it were that easy and
you know I think um
it's useful to think in counter factuals
um you know what if
um and if you believe as historians do
in causation
um then if that one thing causes another
then you also have to believe in
counterfactuals right that if something
hadn't happened then maybe that wouldn't
you know that would have worked
differently
um but uh I think all the things that
led to World War One
um are
multi-causal and nuance and this is what
historians do we make things more
complicated
um and so you know there was no one
thing that could have you know uh that
that could have turned the the tide of
History
um you know and you know oh if only
Hitler had gotten into art school or if
only Fidel Castro had gotten into the
major leagues you know uh uh those are
interesting thought experiments but few
few events in history I think are that
contingent well Hitler is an example of
somebody who's a charismatic leader
that seems to have a really
disproportionate amount of influence
on the tide of History
so you know if you look at Stalin you
could imagine that many other people
could have stepped into that role
and the same goes from any other the
other presidents through or even Mao
it seems that there's a singular nature
to Hitler that you could play the
counter factual
that if there was no Hitler you may have
not had World War II he better than many
leaders in history was able to channel
the resentment of the populace
into a very aggressive expansion of the
military and um I would say skillful
deceit of the entire world in terms of
his plans and was able to effectively
start the war so is it is it possible
that uh
I mean could Hitler have been stopped
could we have avoided if he just got
into art school right
uh or again do you feel like there's a
current of events that was Unstoppable I
mean part of what you're talking about
is uh is Hitler the individual as a sort
of charismatic leader who's able to
mobilize
um you know the the nation
um and part of it is hitlerism right um
his own sort of individual ability to
play for example play off his
subordinates against one another to set
up a system and you know of that of that
nature that that in some ways escalates
violence including uh you know the
violence that leads to the Holocaust
um and some of it is also hitlerism
um as a as a leader cult and we see this
in many other sort of uh you know things
where where a political movement um
surrounds one particular individual who
may or may not be replaceable
um so so yes um the World War II we got
um would have been completely different
um if a different um sort of uh faction
had risen to power in Germany
um but uh but Europe you know Depression
era Europe was so unstable and
democracies collapsed throughout Western
Europe over the course of the 1930s you
know whether they had charismatic uh
totalitarian leaders or not